>> I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO SEE
HOW HE RESPONDS
INTERCEPTION.
OPENING THREE MINUTES AND
TICK W.
ARVIDSSON GETS TO THE PUCK IN
THE CORNER.
>> SO THE TREND CONTINUES WHEN
YOU CAN S S ANDERSON.
JUST A SMIDGE IN FRONT OF HIM.
P.
HE'S IT WASBY CALGARY, SHOT FROE
BY GAU GAUDREAU DOWN THE RIGHT
>> CALGARY'S POWERPOINT UP 5 IN
THE LEAGUE, PETERSON REBOUNDTHE.
THE STAND UP IS NOT CONTAINING
THE BULLET DANAULT KILLING
PENALTIESEM.
NORMALLY A KING W THE
OPPORTUNITY.
FLUNK ARE.
>>
FLIPS IT OFF THE
BACK FROM THE CROSS TOUCH BACK
TO THE POINT SHILLINGTON RIGHT
ON SAVE.
GRUNDSTROM KUPARI.
KINGS KEEPING IT ALIVE. BALANCE
THAT WILL CHANGE DURING THE
COURSENOW DODO FRONT OF THEM THY
EXECUTE THAT AND GO FROM PLAY TO
PLAY TO PLAYY
BACKHANDED PASS TO OUT OF THE
ZONE.
MOORE SENDS IT LOOKING FOR TKAC.
49 BOO THE
GAUDREAU. THE LEFT SIDE ARVIDSSN
STICK SAVED PUCK HOPS IN THE
AIR, THEY BAT AWAY, MAY HAVE HI.
ALIVE, IAFOLLO, CURL AND DRAG TO
THE NET BACKHANDED SHOT SAVE B
THE DECENT
AND THEN HE GOT THE FOLLOW-UP
TRY.